[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
it's a free call at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five well we had a huge
event here at ramsey this morning our
entire team of a thousand folks sat here
and we uh watched the entire premier
screening
of
the new documentary that comes out in
october called borrowed future
and uh we're all a little biased in this
uh building but it's incredible yeah you
don't have to trust us but let me tell
you we had the red carpet we had
chick-fil-a biscuits the team was just
on fire because we've been teasing this
thing for a long time the team has been
working on this for a long time and we
finally got to show
the crew what that's what it's all about
and there was not a dry eye in the house
yeah it is a world-class storytelling
world-class production values and
editing and the whole process and so
you'll be able to see borrowed future on
uh october 14th 14th 14th is the release
date on apple tv and amazon prime and
all the place hulu all the places that
you watch
good documentaries show up and uh good
things like this show up so you'll be
able to find this will be out there just
about everywhere
and more details on that to come but if
you want to be on the launch list you
can go to borrowed future dot com and
just put your email in there and we'll
send you a link and let you know when
you can do it you can actually watch it
from our site it's it's a pay-per-view
process wherever you are
and uh so
we'd love to have you sign up and take a
look at the thing it is um absolutely
incredible
it is obviously about the
the student loan
epic the epic failure of the student
loan movement industry
uh congress how they have screwed you
navient sally may when you finish
watching this your blood will be boiling
because we have we haven't tacked it
down in detail
and there's going to be some people
really really unhappy when this comes
out and it's not going to be you uh it's
going to be these people that have been
screwing you for decades with this epic
failure of a program
it makes um everyone involved i mean
there's so many villains it's hard hard
to be there it's hard to pinpoint one
but yeah there's no way you can have an
opinion after watching this thing where
you don't go
this situation is screwed up and i don't
want anyone i know a part of the student
loan crisis yeah amen amen and if you've
got student loans we're here to help you
with that too we're not mad at you we've
all done stupid things around here
that's how we uh all got started uh we
discovered our lack of perfection and
once we figured that out then we were
able to share
we're much easier where yeah where were
we i've been there where we had messed
up and so i've been there done that
got the t-shirt
it's like my pastor says a man with an
experience is not at the mercy of a man
with an opinion
so that'll preach that's where we are
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five anne is with us
in grand rapids michigan hi ann how are
you
hi dave god bless you
you too
how can we help you
thank you so much
um i'm making
1500 a month on social security
and i make another 500 a month
substitute teaching
and
i'm paying my sister 500 a month
to pay her back the 20 000 ior
and
that will take me three years but in the
meantime
i'm not tithing at all and i'm
and i don't quite know what to do about
that
how old are you
72 okay all right
well i think it's always good when we're
talking about tithing to uh pull back
from the details of the situation
and just um
unpack okay yes those of us that are
christians uh the vast majority of us
believe that the bible says to tithe to
give a tenth of our income to our local
church that's the definition of the word
from an evangelical christian standpoint
and that's what you're calling about so
let's pan back from that then and say
okay what what is god doing
with this tithe thing
why is he teaching us to tithe and then
what are some of the details around it
number one um
he is not teaching us to tithe because
he needs money he's god he doesn't need
money
okay
number two he's not teaching us to tithe
because the local church needs our
support although that is one of the
byproducts of the tithe
but that's not that's not why scripture
teaches us to tithe
your heavenly father who is absolutely
crazy about you
and he loves you little girl
teaches you to give
because it's good for you
it changes you
and that's the reason generosity always
makes all of us smile
generosity always makes our eyes leak
right
and so this is not a rule to be kept by
an angry father
this is a loving
father that says hey little girl
best way to live your life is to be
generous and here's a good rule of thumb
a tenth of your income now if we want to
get technical about the income let's get
technical about it
i'll give you an opinion but i want you
to live in a lot of grace around this
god does not love tithers more than
non-tithers
you don't get brownie points with god
for tithing
that's not why you do it the reason you
do it is it's good for you to learn what
it does to your heart when you're
generous
and that's why giving is good for
everyone that's jesus says better to
give than receive and the reason is what
happens inside of you not because you're
more noble or more altruistic or you're
a better person because you're a giver
rather than a taker you know it has
everything to do with your heart so now
that we've established that there's a
lot of grace around the subject then the
technicality is the the the best
indicator we have is in deuteronomy it
says to tithe on your net
increase
now that would be if are earning a wage
which you said you're earning 500
okay right right
social security we could argue is not
earning
it you paid into it
it's a horrible retirement plan
that you paid way more into it than
you'll ever get out
right and so i'm not sure
i consider that income
you can if you want because if you want
to be a bigger giver it's never a bad
thing
but in my mind with what you described
what you owe your sister has nothing to
do with the equation mathematically i
would be tithing on the 500 worth of
income and then i would pray and ask god
if you think you're supposed to tithe on
the other social security income
so 50 bucks
and i think you can probably pull that
off even in your really really tight
budget yeah absolutely i mean 50 bucks
from your income and i don't know your
your expenses and when it comes down to
the budget but i would take a good look
at the budget and see if we can
fine-tune some things because clearly
giving is something that you're
passionate about it's something that you
want to do and i love your heart and
faithfulness around this and so i think
you look at the budget and go i know we
i don't have a lot coming in but what
are some areas i can shave to make this
50 happen so that i can be generous you
know
i don't think you're 50 off even in your
tight budget one way or the other
um but again you you um you continue to
pray about this and i want you to have a
peace about it i want you to walk i want
everyone in your generosity to walk in
grace
but the principle is there
those that win with money are generous
very few people do we find in all of our
data points that are very good with
money unless they're generous that's the
little secret that nobody talks about
much
are enough
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we take your calls
about your life and your money it's a
free call at triple eight eight two five
five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five two two five you can actually get
through if you die at this moment
guys we really value the input from our
listeners on the ramsey show and
periodically we will do a listener
survey
in uh the survey running right now we
ask listeners how much debt they've paid
off and you know what people told us
they paid off 241 million dollars in
debt that's the people that took the
survey
wow
so if you'd like to take the survey we'd
love to have you do that uh we are
giving away an amazon gift card worth
250
and you will be in the drawing for that
no purchase necessary if you take the
survey
and it's all about this show and what
you think about it so we value your
opinion text the word survey to 33 789
text survey to 33789 or you can go to
ramsey solutions dot com slash
survey either one will work fine brent
is with us in sacramento hi brent
welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave hi george thank you guys so much
for taking my call sure what's up
um yeah i have a question so um i like
you i'm really interested in like real
estate and kind of building up like a
rental income my portfolio
and um i kind of have like a plan to try
to kind of like become financially free
within the next 10 or 15 years thanks to
a pretty big income that i have and so i
was wondering if uh i kind of like a
two-part question if i'm kind of crazy
for thinking to
um basically just kind of cut back on
like my 401k that i'm getting from my uh
company to try to build this portfolio
faster to essentially like quote-unquote
retire off of this um and if i am crazy
for that um
what should it be invested in to kind of
double every year like you say because
right now it's just invested in like the
um the standard like the speculation for
like when i'm expected to retire
okay um how old are you i'm 27. cool and
what do you make
uh in salary it's about 130k and then in
rsu's it's about anywhere between 30 to
50 depending on like what the stocks are
at when i sell them yeah good for you
well done
that's fun
okay well um obviously the rsu's are not
available to you
until they're available they're
restricted stock units so
what are the restrictions on them how
quickly can you get to that money uh
they're quarterly so um like every you
know for three months or so i get
roughly like eight to ten and 10k in the
rfcs
that are released to you to that you can
cash in
correct yeah once a quarter okay
so they're not heavily restricted you
don't have to hold on five years or
something like that
no they were just restricted for like
the first year and so i got a pretty big
chunk uh within the first year that i
actually used to pay off like the
remainder of my debt so thanks for uh
thanks for having me out with that all
right cool well you're doing really well
we teach a thing a process called the
baby steps and i think that uh is
included in
the person who wants to be wealthy in
real estate and makes um you know 150
000 bucks a year at 27 years old so yeah
i i would tell you to first become
debt-free are you
yes i am do you own a home
no i've been saving up and um i have
about 80 grand saved right now to put
into a home but i'm waiting for the
market to kind of cool down a bit okay
cool that's fine good
well and we would say i have three to
six months of expenses set aside as an
emergency fund and then put as big a
stroke on the house as you can put on
the house
and while you're saving for that house
you've done a good job with a good
strong down payment sacramento is a more
expensive market you wouldn't hurt to
even have more obviously
um but we're going to put 15 percent of
our income into retirement and uh into
the 401k and above that you should have
plenty of room as a young single guy to
save like a crazy man towards buying
some real estate
and uh it sounds good i think you're on
your way to doing that i don't think it
keeps you from doing that no absolutely
not and i want you to have it paid for
uh property first before you go
investing in real estate but i think
with that income and it's only going up
from here he's 27 clearly a sharp guy so
i think hey can i live off of 30 and
sock away 100 plus yeah and save that
and start to invest that into property
once you've got the investing plate
spinning and i think you're going to be
just fine you're going to be a
multi-millionaire either way at this
rate
here's the thing you lower your risk
and your oh crap moments
when something comes at you is lowered
risk
the more
you have paid off
and so i'm with george i'm going to go
ahead and buy the house and get the
house paid off and then i'm going to
save and buy my real estate and by the
way that's what i did i'm not asking you
to do something i didn't do
i bought my i got my house paid off and
i saved up and bought my very first
purse of piece of
investment real estate
and uh then and that's the hardest one
by the way because then you got all that
rent that with no payments
that's a lot of money coming in and then
when you've got two of them with all
that rent and no payments
the third one's even easier because
you've got all that rent
and no payments
and now i'm
quite a few pieces of real estate into
this idea
and i've got all that rent
and no payments and life is pretty good
in that situation
yeah i follow a lot of you know these
influencers on social media and they're
in the real estate world and so they're
trying to leverage out their eyeballs
and they go well i'm not even going to
have my own place i'm just gonna rent
and i'm gonna keep getting more and more
mortgages because hey they're paying my
mortgage off for me dave how is that a
dumb idea
it's about as dumb as following the
advice of an influencer on instagram but
yeah um
yeah so you were the original influencer
you were you were doing it
well maybe um i don't know if i ever
qualified for that stuff but um
but the uh uh uh
you know i started buying real estate
the first time when i went broke in my
20s
and much like
much like brent i was a little bit
younger than brent actually
and there was a rage going on then like
is going on now and that's 40 years ago
and
the rage was nothing down real estate as
a matter of fact there was a guy who
wrote a book called nothing down that
was the name of the book he later filed
chapter 11.
um
and uh book on that and lost everything
and all i was in a real estate club
with all these guys that were following
plus or minus those strategies you know
highly leverage lots of debt buy as much
real estate as you can buy it'll all
work out the renters will pay your
payments
and the interesting thing is you know it
felt good at the moment because like i
became a millionaire by the time i was
26 doing that and i i owned a bunch of
real estate i own 4 million worth of
real estate and i had 3 million worth of
debt that means you're a millionaire 4-3
right and so um but i also had
no money
no money it all went back into deals i
had no money it all went back into deals
and as soon as the bank just flinched
they just took me out in a tsunami just
knocked me over because i built a house
of cards and a house of cards isn't
stable but back to my story all of my
buddies
there were three guys
that were kind of old farts in the club
right the club was like 100 people this
real estate investors club
and these old guys wouldn't do it the
cool way they were paying for everything
or they had almost no debt they'd maybe
borrow a little bit but it was like a
you know they put down like 70 or
something mostly cash deals
and uh i remember talking about i'm like
dude you could do three times as many
deals and he goes yeah but i'll be here
three times as long oh
ten years from the time i'm in that club
later
i don't know a single person in that
club that had not gone broke wow every
one of them that followed these
influencers you're talking about type
advice
including the guy who wrote the freaking
book
had gone through bankruptcy wow and so
you know it's just it's a it's fool's
gold
to uh because the leverage will come
back and bite your butt off
and you you'll just be standing there
and it wasn't just me i'm not i'm not
pregnant i mean it wasn't different
because it was dave and well dave's just
wounded because of his experience
no dave learned from his experience
there's a difference there's a
difference between wounded and learning
you
know that hot stove burnt my hand when i
laid my hand on it and so i don't touch
hot stoves anymore yeah so strange yeah
well i i love to see people this young
in their 20s wanting to do it and
wanting to do it the right way so i
think brent's on to something here if he
can follow the baby steps and do it with
cash he's going to be doing just fine
but all of his buddies
that are on instagram are
going to be really really concerned
about how slow he's moving oh yeah and
the people who build wealth and keep it
are never on the cover of fast company
magazine they're on the cover of slow
company the tortoise never makes it to
the cover dave the tortoise the hair is
always on the cover the tortoise never
makes it and every time i read the book
the tortoise wins the race this is the
ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today he is the host of the fine
print
our latest uh podcast that has gone out
it is a sea it's in season one there are
10 episodes
that uh if you watch this you will find
all the different ways that you should
have read the fine print and someone's
taking advantage of you oh yeah and our
latest one is all about these buy now
pay later services and you've probably
heard the names after pay and klarna and
affirm and dave i've been digging into
this and their marketing is hilarious
here's what they they sell themselves to
companies
by saying this we create financial
freedom for your customers
that sounds like something we want to
create financial freedom for people and
the way they create financial freedom
for customers is by putting them in debt
that makes sense
right you don't have to read the fine
print to understand that this is a
stupid idea and this is just modern day
layaway back in the day you go to the
store yeah but layaway doesn't have an
interest rate no and you have to wait to
get the item until you actually pay for
it in full yeah with buy now pay later
you get it now this is the payday lender
of amazon prime
yes that's what these guys are i mean if
you can't make if you have to make
payments on a shirt
[Music]
hint
you shouldn't be buying the shirt yeah
oh my gosh do we need your grandmother
to remind you of something like this and
box your little ears america
this is huge among gen z and millennials
because what they do is they go well i
spend 100 i could spend 25 and free up
that money in my budget yeah i get to
use all this i get to keep my money now
this is the greatest it's the you know i
was thumbing through uh we're moving and
so i was packing and i found the
newspaper
from uh
the 1970s when nixon resigned
and it was the nashville tennessean
uh which the newspaper is actually still
in existence it's no longer a paper it's
not a pamphlet
a left-wing rag but um
but the uh uh and it's really about five
pages now but it used to be a legitimate
thick mostly people used to but i mean
i'm going through this thing
looking at the cars for sale of the
1970s and what they cost
and looking at the houses i was looking
at there used to be these things people
called the classified ads
and you could put your lawnmower for
sale in the classified ads and you could
sell your you know your dog and the
classified ads and you could do whatever
in the classified because they were set
up by classification oh
this is old school
it was craigslist before craig was born
and so uh you know i'm going through
this thing and i was amazed that the
language is the same
three easy
payments
15 easy just make easy
so easy
and i was remembering my my grandfather
going there's no such thing honey there
are no easy
payments they always hurt yeah that what
what's easy is the purchase of something
that you can't afford with money you
don't have to impress people you don't
even really like that's what's easy the
payments are never easy
even if they're small
they at least remind you how stupid you
were that you bought a shirt
it was a shirt
oh my god it's crazy and what's even
crazier is klarna uh they tout this to
companies the store order increases by
45 when you use klarna they don't put
that in front of the customer they put
that in front of the company well they
didn't even spend their money on the
name i mean what a horrible name i know
it sounds like karma karma gone sideways
yeah it's bad that'd be a better tagline
so we dig into this it's 24 minutes long
it's fun it's narrative rachel cruz
joins me as the expert on the topic
she's dug into this we talked to a real
life that's the one that's one that
launched this week yes this launch just
last week and uh this girl spent ten
thousand dollars at lululemon using buy
now pay later my brain melted down when
i heard that and that's only buying two
things from lululemon yeah imagine
sweatpants extraordinary that's all it
takes
and so that we dig into this we have a
homework a freaking lululemon
it's unbelievable yeah you just can't
george will always have a job
that's true
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five check it out it's
called the fine print anywhere great
podcasts are sold oh wait they're free
how is this free check it out check it
out i don't know because i'm paying you
i'm not sure how this is working but
don't think about it too long somewhere
in there my brain's hurting all right
caitlin is with us in minnesota hi
caitlin what's up in your world
hi dave um it's an honor to talk to you
um
i
i uh
so me and my husband have been married
for about four years and sorry i'm like
really nervous that's okay we've never
lost a patient you'll be okay
um and
we operate by what i call the roommate
method
um it's where
you know we have a mortgage payment i
give him my half he pays the bill right
and
i know we want to do the dave ramsey we
want to do all your baby steps he's
already our thousand dollar emergency
fund
but he wants to take care of his debt
and he wants me to take care of my dad
and i tried to talk to him and i don't
know
what to say what to do how to and we've
been through like the money and marriage
seminar last year we've done financial
peace university together
i know i know
all of it
i know i'm gonna make you repeat the
second grade here
it hurts my heart a lot because i love
him and i know that if we can get
through this
you know and get through
our p to get through this
that things will be great
i just i don't know if i'm not saying
the right thing how old is he
he is um we're both 28. okay i thought
you married a child for a second i just
want to get the ages right before we dug
in you guys please stop saying that
about him because he's really handsome
i'm sure he's a great husband what it
feels like
these are my toys and these are your
toys and i'll play with my toys and you
play with your toys but when you guys
said i do
it was we from then on out there's no
roommate method there's no it's husband
and wife
and that means joint accounts that means
conversation communication combining
everything and it's now our debt yeah
but he's you're saying he's not in there
it's and i don't
totally blame him
what's his excuse
what's his excuse well
he hasn't given me an excuse so he just
whines
no he doesn't whine yeah he is you don't
talk about it a lot yeah but um his wife
is calling me on national radio after
you've been through financial peace
university and been to the thing so yeah
that's called why not yeah no really
this is this is this is bad
so um
okay so what you've got to do with him
is you're gonna have to get to the
bottom of what his problem is
what's his
objection
why does it why does he not want to
combine after four years why do we not
why are we not french we we
it's we yeah when you're married it's we
not yours and mine we're not splitting
the mayonnaise the baloney and the other
stuff in the refrigerator that's my
mustard keep your hands off of it we're
not roommates yeah
yeah
and it's not good for your marriage and
it's not good for your wealth building
it's not good for your relationships
it's not good for your level of
communication there's nothing here
that's good so why is he insistent upon
doing things that are not good i'm
confused you are too
so maybe he needs to maybe he needs to
defend himself on that
yeah well and i kind of
i've been the free spirit i've never
been good at handling my money but i
want us to do it together so we can
learn together you know
yeah i mean if you two laid out a plan
that both of you agreed to called a
monthly budget
would you stick to it if you had a vote
on the plan
oh gosh yeah well then the free spirit
is not the problem yeah but a free
spirit's not the problem because even a
free spirit can stick to a plan
yeah if they have a vote and a voice in
the plan now he doesn't get to lay out
the plan and then make you do it that's
not what we're talking about no and he
wouldn't because we've tried before and
i i don't know what happened
to be honest
but we've tried before
to do a point to do a budget do you guys
have a why that you've laid out when you
talk or is he just not want to talk does
he just shut down
no we've talked we've done the whole
dreaming thing we want you know to
be build wealth we both want to change
change a leg change generate like our
generation
you know we want to have a good legacy
like you know uh it's are you sure it's
a good legacy for him
legacy
are you sure it's not just you
we've talked we have talked about it
before
and he has said it i think he carries a
lot of shame with having so much
like because coming into the
relationship it was his debt
and i have debt too yeah but like you
said we get married it's ours but he's
here
he's shameful for richer
unto thee
all my worldly goods
yeah i pledge
for better for worse
for richer for poorer
unto thee
all my worldly goods i pledge
this is a relationship
issue
it's affecting your money
and i'm getting to the bottom of it if
i'm
this is not okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is
our co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
one of the number one questions we get
here on the air
and by email and on our other podcasts
is how do i get my spouse on board
and
number one
there's not a magic formula
for that
number two
it is absolutely necessary that you do
get them on board
because working a separate plan will
eventually cause you to
work a separate plan
the number of people who build wealth
and have high quality marriages
30 years into a separate plan is
approaching zero that's your data but i
think it's right it's actual data wow i
mean the 10 000 millionaires that we
interviewed the vast majority of them
said i don't remember the number it was
in the 70 80 percentile that their
spouse and them work together
so there's a high correlation between
the ability to build wealth there's a
high correlation between high quality
communication and shared values
in them to having a high quality
marriage duh
shocker
now how do we how do we what are the
what's your best shot
what's our best shot around here of
getting the spouse
to see that they need to be on board i
can't make this basket on board yeah but
i can help them see how important it is
number one data
says that you're gonna have a crummy
marriage and your likelihood of building
wealth is gonna suck
if you're not on the same page and
you're not working together pulling the
wagon up the hill together
both of you have a vote
you know
saver versus spender free spirit versus
nerd
abundance versus scarcity and you
balance each other out and if two people
just like get married one of you is
unnecessary so it's good that opposites
attract
but how do you get the spouse to see the
need
i think the biggest uh
piece is starting with that why and
having that shared goal if you can't get
excited about the future why do you care
about your present
why does it even matter to get out of
debt if you feel like you like laying in
your own poop and so what we got to do
is find a why that gets us on fire a
little bit and what i like to do some
people get inspired by the math a lot of
people haven't even done the math on
what that payment would be like to have
back in their life what could they do
what is the interest we're currently
paying some people need a little bit of
that nerdery to go oh my gosh i'm paying
sally may 600 bucks a month no we're
getting rid of this thing so once you
combine the y and the math and then you
pair it with something like financial
peace university or you both read the
total money makeover you need to create
that shared language because then they
understand it's not just what dave said
we need to get out of that do the debt
snowball
it becomes a no we decided that our goal
is to change our family tree we decided
that we have bigger goals in life than
to pay sally may for the next 20 years
and once you do that things change
behavior change habits change and you
start to see some progress and then you
go oh my gosh we can do this and then
every couple that stands on the stage
they go dave our marriage is better yeah
what was the key to getting out of debt
communication the budget but the two
things that come up every time just
about yeah right there you know and they
almost always raise their income yeah
but you can't raise your income if the
one at home is whining about you working
and it's just the whole thing it work it
pulls together and and
um
it bothers me when i hear someone say
hey we went through financial peace
university we went to the marriage and
money event
we did a dream date together we laid out
you know some of our why
and then the spouse still won't come to
the table that makes me think something
else is going on yeah because there's no
at that point you have the information
in front of you that a logical human
being says uh
the pride i've got that i brought the
dead in i gotta let that down and we
gotta work together it's our best shot
the uh the shame i have because i
brought in more death than she brought
in i gotta lay that down because it's
our best shot as a couple
um
and so i
uh uh
i don't know what's going on there but
something else is going on that's not in
the equation that we're hearing
that that is causing that because it's
not a simple thing of we just don't have
a shared vision yeah because if you can
get on a shared vision then you will
come back and do the practical stuff to
hit the vision
you know you'll you'll dial back in and
do the tactical do the budget together
make the the sacrificial decisions
together make the decision to sell one
of the cars or whatever it is you got to
do to get your budding gear
you'll do that stuff once you see where
you're going and it's worth the trip
yeah but you won't do it with thank god
it's friday oh god it's monday and you
won't do it with i'm a victim and you
won't do it with the little man can't
get ahead and the system's rigged and oh
my god the whining that goes on in this
culture
the arrogance of entitlement is
unbelievable
but if you just sit out there and say
there's a thing i can go get that thing
if i'll do the steps to get that thing
then then that thing can just be
financial security financial peace yeah
and i think you're right there's there's
a theme i'm seeing here with people that
can't get on board and it's either
selfishness or shame it's either well
this is mine and that's yours and you
deal with yours and i'll deal with mine
or it's the shame where they go well
this is my dad i don't want you to have
the burden of that and there is that
pride you gotta suck up and go no we're
a team now and i didn't sign up for a
roommate i don't know about her but i
don't want to live with a roommate for
30 years i want to live with a grown
adult who decided that we do things
together as a family and i think
marriage counseling may be in order for
them to get on the same page and dig
into the root issue here because i don't
think it's just the budget and money i
think there is something more serious
going on yeah and it scares me what it
could be melanie is with us in
indianapolis hi melanie welcome to the
ramsay show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up
um i'm actually calling just i'm trying
to narrow down the question but it's
how do i go about making an income when
i'm transitioning from working full-time
to being a full-time mom
oh
when'd you have your baby
um in april so she's five months old
wonderful
how fun
oh fun we had our little grandson down
at the lake house this weekend he's
three he's two months old and uh they're
fun when they're that age they don't
really cause much trouble except a dirty
diaper yeah
and uh that's it so yeah that's awesome
so you want to work or not
well i guess i'm trying to figure out if
i'm even approaching this right my
husband makes about 40 000 a year
45 000 a year
um
but last year he was a little bit off
because
most of his
commission comes from um
he's a salesman at a music store and so
most of his commission is
rentals for schools
yeah so with covid
we were down a little bit and so we just
built up a little bit more debt than we
really wanted to
so do you want to work or not
i think i do i want to
i want to contribute in some way
but are you going to start a small
business and do it from home
while baby is taking a nap or are you
going back into the workplace
i'm wanting to do something at home
something i can pretty much do online
okay
good okay so so you so that you're there
with baby and you work around baby and
you kind of control your own time frames
yeah okay but if you could add ten
thousand dollars to this equation in a
year
you would feel good
yes i could add about
ten thousand to twenty thousand okay
cool well that's realistic we just need
to define what it is you wanna go after
it sounds to me like you are a christy
wright business boutique customer
um
material business boutique equipping
women to make money doing what they love
has a lot of ladies who want to stay at
home but earn an income from home while
watching over the kiddos
and a lot of them have online businesses
or freelance businesses or different
things where they control the time
frames
uh and so that you know while the kids
are at school while the kids are napping
whatever it is five o'clock in the
morning before they get up you do some
work and you create some income and
christy can show you how to do that i'll
send you a copy of the book business
boutique it is a number one bestseller
and if you'd like to come to nashville
we have a three-day event
in october
and uh it's christy and me and john
deloney and a bunch of
high-powered ladies on the stage
teaching women how to run a business
and
it is absolutely incredible and i'll
give you a couple tickets to that as
well and bring a friend with you so it's
business boutique in nashville and i'll
send you the book and that because
here's what you're gonna have to do
you're gonna flesh out the whole process
of figuring out
what skills you have and how to make
money with those skills on
on a limited controlled schedule yeah i
want to throw one more thing in uh kelly
will pick up i want to give you ken
coleman's career assessment to help you
figure out because it sounds like you're
not really sure what you want to do yet
so going through that will give you that
clarity to figure out something you
actually enjoy doing
that's a big key yeah the career
assessment is pretty incredible
uh so yeah you can take that we'll give
that to you as a gift as well all for
the birthing of the baby that's awesome
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey
ramsey solutions dot com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice george campbell ramsey
personality host of the fine print and
the entree leadership podcast is my
co-host today
open phones here as we talk about your
life and your money the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
so george when i first started teaching
this stuff
these principles of getting out of debt
living on lessons you make live on a
plan
always be generous
uh you know this whole process of the
basic principles of personal finance
common sense biblical financial
principles grandma's common sense
um
i had just gone through a bankruptcy and
so i was hardcore and still am to this
day
anti-debt don't borrow money because i
discovered that it not only can destroy
your life but on top of that it can hold
you back and keep you from becoming
wealthy so i was the get out of that guy
from day one
and so we started teaching this class
people were coming to the class
and um
they would and i would start this radio
show and people they would call in and
say okay now what do i do first do i do
investing for the kids college
what about my retirement and what about
this credit card do i pay it off and
what about this car which one where does
it fit in the plant and and where do i
and what about saving for an emergency
and oh i don't want to pay off my house
someday and i want to buy a house
someday and oh and and they would start
asking all these questions
and
i figured out if you have like 17 things
in front of you and you try to do all of
them a little bit nothing gets done
the power of focus
and a clear path
a clear plan a clear list of priorities
started to emerge because i started to
understand that personal finance is 80
behavior and only about
20 head knowledge
and so i first said okay you need to get
out of debt that's your first thing
and then i went well probably not the
house so the house is like a different
thing but we need to get out of debt
with the house
and before we do retirement we really
need an emergency fund because you'll
cash out your 401 k
if you lose your job
and you need money to pay the house
payment and you don't have an emergency
fund so you need the emergency fund
really for you before 1k so i started to
kind of put these things in order
and i'm looking around at what some of
the people in financial planning
community are doing and a lot of it i
agreed with and there's some basic
guidelines in there i didn't make up a
properly funded emergency fund is three
to six months of expenses i didn't make
that up that was been out there for a
bazillion years i didn't even make up
the debt snowball i'm best known for it
but i didn't make it up i saw it
somewhere it made sense to me pay off
the smallest debt rather than the
highest interest rate because you get
that zoom zoom that kick in the pants
psychologically when you get things paid
off
and so this
if you want to eat an elephant it's
overwhelming
how do you eat an elephant one bite at a
time a bite at a time
uh so we started teaching what we called
the baby steps
and the first baby step was get out of
debt
later on i went back and i added a new
baby step one
first have a thousand dollars
and then
usually that snowball and get out of
debt because
people had no money and like they blow a
tire i mean it'd be like a hundred
dollar thing
and then they would just quit because oh
god the whole thing fell apart i was
getting out of debt i was doing fine
like tire went and now i'm done and they
had no margin all so i put a thousand
dollars in there not for an emergency
fund but just for a little bit of wiggle
room so when a little emergency comes up
it doesn't derail you emerge it doesn't
derail you emotionally so thus was born
the baby steps wow who knew they would
be so controversial
right
did you ever think you'd get so much
well i you know i agree with dave on
this but you know when it comes to baby
step four here's really there's all kind
but here's the thing at the end of the
day millions of people have done it and
they go dave this worked and my whole
life i couldn't figure out how to manage
my money and i just followed a proven
plan someone else's process and it
changed everything it turned into the
book the total money makeover the proven
plan to financial fitness is the
subtitle
and um you sold a few of those sold uh
approaching 10 million copies now
and um some of them are on shelves
collecting dust have never been open
some of them are on coffee tables as a
really nice coaster and have never been
opened but some of them have actually
been read
and we have documented proof that
millions and millions and millions of
families have not only gotten out of
debt
but have started to become millionaires
baby steps millionaires using
these
baby steps
it is a proven plan now you can work
whatever plan you want to work
but don't call it my plan
call it your plan
this is the ramsey plan this is the plan
everyone at ramsey has agreed on
this is the shortest path
and to the extent you modify it
i think you lengthen
the time it's going to take you to
become wealthy
this is the shortest distance between
where you are
and financial peace the shortest
distance between where you are and a
level of wealth that allows you to
retire with dignity begin to change your
family tree and have some peace in your
life baby step one is
save one thousand dollars for your
starter emergency fund
you should do that in 30 days or less
some of you have more than a thousand
dollars in a savings account today set
aside one thousand dollars that is baby
step one you're done
that easy some of you did it
instantaneously some of you will do it
out of this paycheck it's a thousand
dollars shut up do it now quickly
immediately
roll coins sell crap out of their corner
of your couch put stuff on ebay those
all golf clubs you got 17 sets of all
golf clubs get rid of all of them you
know all this stuff right and and so get
the thousand dollars quickly
any money you have
that is above that that is not in a
retirement account
goes on to baby step two yeah so once we
have that foundation that buffer we move
on to baby step two where we pay off all
of our consumer debt except the house
using the debt snowball method
which is this is where we're going to
lay out all of our payments
regardless of the interest rate this is
what gets people we're ignoring the
interest rate we're just doing it by the
balance so we're going to lay them all
out from smallest to largest and we're
going to pay minimum payments on all of
those debts except for that smallest one
and attack it with a vengeance laser
focus like your freaking life depended
on it you work so much that your kids
don't know your name and it doesn't
matter because they're up for sale on
ebay anyway
i mean you got to get with it you sell
so much stuff the kids think they're
next the dogs on ebay and the cat's on
craigslist i mean everything is gone
we're not going out to eat don't talk to
me about going out to eat you're broke
and in debt
you have to get out of debt you can go
out to eat later whiner get a skillet
and cook something my grandmother used
to say can i fry you an egg get you
something to cook come on now seriously
people it doesn't it costs 1 10 to cook
a meal at home what it does to go to a
restaurant and buy it and the reason is
restaurant is entertainment it is not
food
i'm not against restaurants i love
restaurants i will go to one tonight but
i can freaking afford it i'm not broken
and dead anymore because i didn't go out
to eat for a period of time and you're
not going on vacation either going on
vacation you're broke you've got to be
kidding me
so you're going to work your debts off
smallest to largest in
that order three to six months of
expenses set aside is baby step four
three where you have that set aside for
your emergency fund and you're set up
for that
and then it goes on to baby step four
fifteen percent of your income into
retirement
five is kids college savings the sixes
we're gonna pay off the house early the
typical family working this system pays
it off it pays off the house in seven to
ten years and they're millionaires in
around 11 years i'm incredible
[Music]
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to puretalk they use
the same network as the larger providers
for much less for just 30 a month get
unlimited talk text and six gigs of data
with no contract the average family
saves over 70 dollars a month by
switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five if you're like most people
you've got more uh more than enough on
your mind right now getting the kids
where they need to be keeping up with
the bills staying on top of work and
family it's exhausting
stressful the money thing oh man for a
lot of people
i remember it just makes your throat
tight your stomach come up in your
throat it's just bad listen there's a
plan that we were just talking about in
the last segment that'll help you get on
track the baby steps
and the way we teach you how to do that
the most efficiently and the way we
develop those baby steps over all these
years is through financial peace
university
it'll show you how to get out of debt
save money build wealth for the future
be outrageously generous
you can stream all nine lessons on your
own or and or you can join a class
with other people so you're not figuring
out alone people are good to be around
you know
in the only way to experience financial
peace university is with a ramsey plus
membership
plan works every time
ask the six million people who have done
it
start your free trial at ramsey plus and
get into financial peace university it's
a free trial text the word trial to 33
789 that's trial to 33 789 our question
today comes from blinds.com they're a
wonderful american company i've been
endorsing these guys for a long time got
their window blinds in my own home
personally find out for yourself why
they're the number one online retailer
of custom window coverings you get free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run all the time you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsey to
get the best possible deal
today's question comes from robert in
tennessee to say the home selling market
in tennessee is hot is an understatement
but i also have heard it's the worst
time to buy a home for that very reason
the value of our home has gone up
considerably and my wife and i would
like to sell in order to upgrade to a
larger home is now the right time to
cash in our equity and make this
purchase
what do you think it's a good question
from robert uh well he's saying the
value of his home has gone up and you
know everyone's has because it's a hot
market and so there's this fever to go
well i want to sell i can upgrade i can
upgrade but here's the problem when you
go to upgrade well now you're trying to
buy a house that is also appreciated in
value and so there's kind of a trade-off
here where you've got to go
what's the right move financially
regardless of where the market's at can
i afford that upgraded house is it a
wise move for us to do
you know regardless of what your house
is going to sell for yeah the the
problem with selling at the top of the
market is you have to buy at the top of
the market
the problem with selling in a frenzy to
market where there's 17 offers in two
days
is you have to buy
in a frenzied market
where there's 17 offers
in two days
and so unless you are somehow for some
reason making a
some kind of a different move
where uh you cash out now but use that
money later
or use it in a different way
then just to buy in a frenzied market
and sell in a frenzy market is
you know
it's frenzied hello i mean high stress
scenario to do it right now and so i
think the breakdown at least in the way
you've worded your question the
breakdown in your wife's logic is
she sees that you can get a lot for your
house but hasn't considered that it's
going to take a lot to buy the next one
and so i don't think homes are going to
come down
they've gone way up but not artificially
it's just a drive it was an artificial
demand and it was a covered supply
demand in the
in the
basically the new housing market the
supply chain got screwed up because the
lumber market and a few other markets
they couldn't get houses out of the
ground and labor market
couldn't get houses out of the ground
and that slowed up and created a supply
demand problem meaning there was a
shortage of housing and that drove this
market and created us a little bit of
artificial inflation but i don't think
next year houses are going to come down
i don't think the year after that
they're going to come down
and why do i think that
because i got my real estate license in
1978
and if you look back on the real estate
market since 1950 so 75 years
you've not seen houses go down
in value in 75 years year over year
except in a few markets once
and that was 2008
when there was a housing bubble
and there was a a real problem a housing
economic crisis this is not a housing
economic crisis this is an overall
supply chain screw-up due to covet
and
the economic suppression that came along
with making everyone sit in their homes
on their thumbs
and it screwed up the economy now you
can argue about the medical part of it
or not but you can't really argue about
the economic part of it it screwed up
the economy
making people sit at home and not work
screwed up the economy straight up okay
so
would you buy and sell a house this year
only if you want the stress of selling
in a frenzied market and buying in a
frenzy market
i don't worry about the height of the
prices as much as i do the process the
process
to sell a typical home today
is you're basically having an auction
and the process for buying a typical
home today is you're basically having an
auction and that is a high stress
scenario for most people and people end
up doing things they regret later in
high stress scenarios so
unless you've got a situation where you
can move i'm moving this year but i sold
a ridiculously large house that really
would have been very tough to sell in
any kind of market other than this
and i thought you know what god if you
want to sell this house i've had fun
with it for 12 years this sounds like a
really good time to get out and i got
out
and i cashed out but i'm doing something
different there than just moving from
house to house to house to house you
know about a house but it's not nowhere
near as big and all this and so
we didn't even say we need to downsize
we didn't say that we said hey we're
going to cash out at the top on this and
we'll just buy something over here
that's a little different than i want to
move up and and neither one of the homes
we bought are typical either oh yeah and
also our team the ramsey research team
just released the q2 state of personal
finance study and they found that the
majority of people are waiving
inspections and appraisals because of
how crazy it is they are way overpaying
above asking price i'm not talking about
two thousand dollars more we're talking
fifty seventy five thousand dollars
above asking to get a guy on our team
sold at 750 000 house the other day 120
000 above market and he took one of the
22 offers oh my goodness
and that was about a month that's what
they're going to be dealing with if they
sell this house well now they've got a
whole other situation over here so i
don't think it's this hey the housing
market's hot let's all sell right now
it's not going to work out like that
well i mean
if you're going if you've got someplace
else to live until the thing cools off
that's okay but uh to buy and the the
repurchasing of it is the problem in
most people's situation right now i will
tell you this too
in the last 90 days the market has
calmed down considerable i'd say the
activity is about half of what it was in
middle tennessee
it's still very hot but it was
quite hot frenzied 90 days ago yeah that
story i just told you was about 90 days
ago that that happened rachel's with us
rachel's in wichita kansas hi rachel
welcome to the ramsay show
hi jay hi george it's a blessing to get
to talk to you today you too what's up
well i have a question regarding our
retirement savings i'm 51 my husband's
55 and we recently reached what i
consider a milestone amount in our 401k
or his of about 750 000 way to go and
yay
thank you we followed your uh investment
recommendations as far as the four
different types of mutual funds and it
worked oh at this point it did work yes
it worked beautifully at this point
we're wondering is there a point when we
should move some or all of this into
some more conservative investments
no
let me explain to you where that comes
from that's called the asset allocation
model and it's a theory in financial
planning that is widely accepted in the
financial planning community
as you can guess i'm contrarian to a lot
of things that are widely accepted in
any community
much less the financial planning
community so the theory is is that when
you turn 60 or so you should start
moving your money away from any kind of
equities into bonds and money markets to
stabilize uh remove the volatility in
your golden years okay
that's that's that's the basis of the
theory and so by the time you're 70 you
should have almost nothing in
stock type mutual funds you should be
largely in bonds and money markets and
very stable type instruments at that
point that's the standard financial
planning model again it's called the
asset allocation model
the problem with that is with someone
that has built the level of wealth that
you have built is you're probably never
going to actually touch the million
dollars that you have
you're probably just going to live off
the income that it creates
okay
and if you move it to where it creates
less income
i don't see the purpose in that you can
afford to ride out any waves
that that model says you can't afford to
ride out so you need to stabilize the
volatility and since you've got
suspension sufficient assets i'm 61 i
have zero in bonds zero in money markets
due to volatility all of mine is
invested in growth stock type mutual
funds i'm going to ride it out and i can
afford to you can too
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage raymond and stephanie
are with us hey guys how are you hey
dave hey george great welcome happy to
be here so good to have you where do you
guys live we're out of phoenix arizona
cool welcome to nashville very fun to
have you and all the way over here to do
a free scream how much did you pay off
we paid off
229 000
900 and we also
cash rolled an additional 130 000 wow
wow and how long did this take
41 months all right good for you and
your range of income during that time we
started about 240 and finished at around
200. cool what do y'all do for a living
i'm in construction product sales
and i was in um escrow and title until
covet hit and then i took the early
retirement all right good for you i like
it
so what kind of debt was this 230 000
bucks
it was the mortgage dave oh look at the
weird people
paid for house i love it very cool
what's the house worth
uh probably about seven hundred thousand
ah it's all yours yeah i love it
congratulations thank you well tell us
about this 41 month journey what puts
you on to
doing the stuff that we teach well our
our story goes back a lot farther than
that um 41 months ago we just got sick
and tired of being sick and tired and
broke
and uh our you know we had a great
credit score but we didn't have squat
and uh so if you go back when we first
got married some 31 years ago
uh we had more bills than we had money
and so before we even heard of dave
ramsey we created our own debt snowball
and we just figured a lot like yourself
and probably a lot of other people we
just needed to pay off the lowest bill
i took a second job did a side hustle
working at a dock and loading and
unloading trucks uh while i was working
my uh my job and uh just took one bill
at a time tore it up and uh we were
performing our plasectomies before we
even knew what they were i love it and
uh got rid of them one by one but of
course we were doing it our way and we
never heard of dave ramsey at that point
so we did a whole lot of stupid after
that i just did a lot of crying when we
were trying to do bills with no money
yeah she was sitting at the kitchen
table crying and i'm saying no this
isn't gonna happen we need to change
things yeah so
but then we just got rid of all that
debt and created new debt bought new
homes leased cars
and just created just a bunch more debt
the good thing that we did all the way
along even though we didn't do it in
your right order was we were
contributing to 401k from day one 15
great and then one day stephanie came
home and said i heard this guy dave
ramsey
on the radio and i said dave ramsey we
picked up your book i read chapter one
i'm like we're doing this
but
kktr ktar radio huh yeah they're in
phoenix that's a great radio station and
uh but we kind of kept thinking we could
do it our way so we had one credit card
for points you know made decent money we
didn't have nothing in the bank but we
figured it was okay and
finally like i said you know we got to
the point where uh three and a half
years ago just about where we were just
tired and we needed a plan for
retirement and we thought we need to
kick it into high gear now yeah so we uh
we downsized at that point uh tore up
the one and only credit card that we had
and we took and taught our first fpu
class oh wow uh virtually last year it's
hard to not do the stuff when you're
done right we thought we we better give
up the credit card we can't pretty much
yeah right right and then uh
created our little uh graph and
just took every lump sum we could and
paid it all off wow
that's so cool i told ray when we
downsized i said we can do this we can
do this in five and a half to six years
we started the plan i'm like we're doing
this in three and a half years
[Laughter]
he's like put it on a chart and we did
it so i love it that is so cool dave we
were like the business fable of the um
the
the chicken and the pig you know with
the ham and the eggs where the the
chicken's involved but the pig is really
committed yeah uh well we were the
chicken for the longest period of time
and then we decided you know what if
we're going to do this we need to be all
in pig committed that's it i like it
that's it very good all in i'm going to
i'm going to put what it takes i'm going
to do what it takes yeah so what what do
you think the key was uh to getting out
of debt for you two
commitment and perseverance i mean it
was just a lot of just
giving it our all and not giving up and
um
as you always ask who our biggest
cheerleaders were i mean we were each
others i mean we didn't share a whole
lot with people because we're you know
embarrassed or whatever or didn't know
how to share certain things so
um together we just said hey this is
what we're doing you know
yeah and then i'd say for me i mean it
was definitely our lord and savior jesus
christ we wouldn't be here today
without him so i i knew that needed to
be there and then you really have to
have a tight loving relationship with
the person you're doing this with no
doubt about it and if we weren't on the
same page there's no way yeah and i know
steph had a hard time with the budget
uh i'm
i'm not friendly to the budget
but yeah definitely being committed and
disciplined and and to know why you're
doing what you're doing to to change
your future and your family tree so 31
years of marriage and this is the first
time you've ever been debt-free that's
it completely yeah way to go guys yeah
how much is in the 401k
uh
we're uh over a million
so so you're approaching a two million
dollar net worth then that's it your
baby steps millionaires and you're dead
yep yep way to go guys actually our net
worth
yeah we're actually probably closer to
three million okay so i had the 750 000
house and the one million dollar net and
the one million dollar uh 401k that's
all i had yeah yeah it must be some
other stuff okay good three million is
not bad dude
for a guy who used to work on the dock
right well done man
well done you guys rocking it thanks
love it that is so cool so how does it
feel
it feels amazing it feels surreal you
know because it's it's like anything
else once you've been doing it and
trying and again our journey was we were
trying to do it our way for so long and
then when you finally get on it
if it doesn't feel like you you really
didn't cross the finish line because it
was such a process to get there you know
and but now i think our biggest joy is
trying to mentor
and and give you know wherever we can
for other people and i think that's
that's the joy that we get you know we
use your your name as a cuss word all
the time well hey dave ramsey you got to
do his plan
i think we're p we're bugging people so
much
this is how we did it you know we love
this guy you know do it our way do it
his way you know
well i mean you're standing there worth
three million dollars so it worked huh
there you go there's that i mean like
you said you kind of went at it side
angled a little bit on a couple of the
steps but you still got there yeah and
uh very very well done very proud of
y'all thanks for teaching financial
peace too it's got to be inspiring to
the couples that are in there to have
their coordinator be worth three million
bucks yeah i'm listening to you
everything i'll take their advice yeah
yeah well we also wanted to thank you
dave because what you do and all your uh
on-air personalities you guys add so
much and it's it's really what
invigorated us and and you're you're
teaching the way you do it in such a
candid way but also a brutally honest
way when you need to i love it it's it's
common sense at its best and there's
just not enough of that so thank you
thank you we got a copy of the legacy
journey for you that's what you're
living in now is the new legacy and of
course a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away and pay it
forward to somebody so
very very well done you guys so proud of
you heroes i love meeting baby steps
millionaires it's awesome very cool good
for you guys very very well done raymond
and stephanie phoenix arizona 230 000
paid off in 41 months that's the house
and everything
making 240 to 200. count it down let's
hear a debt free scream ready babe three
two one
we're dead free
[Applause]
look at them with the kiss step up i
love it this is how it's done incredible
man that's fun hand in hand that's what
happens when you get on the same page so
you can do it if you're 31 or if you've
been married for 31.
either one you can do it either way but
you got to get on the same page yep and
um they said that was essential to
making a three million dollar net worth
look at that ding ding yeah of course we
don't know anything at ramsey about
you know building wealth we're just
about getting people out of debt that's
right we're not really good for you if
you want to build wealth so
you shouldn't really follow our stuff if
you really want to become wealthy
so say the trolls
this is the ramsey shop
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at
825-5225
[Music]
michelle is with us in milwaukee hi
michelle welcome to the ramsey show
hi dave thank you so much for all that
you've been doing i've been listening to
your advice since i was a teenager went
through high school and college wow and
graduated in 2001 and
came out wanting to start my own
business and have peace with it and i
did
and i've been able to run my own music
studio since 2001 2003
got in a massive car accident by 2004 i
had 125k worth of debt
and was able to pay off student loan
debt and medical debt and then purchase
a home by 2009 so i wanted to thank you
for that advice thank you and
um was wondering now that i'm married
and my husband and i have gone through
another long stretch of that 2014. we
were on our way only had 50k worth of
debt i got cancer and then we had to
start over scratching with the medical
debt so now fast forward um sold the
house passed now pass coded um pre-coded
2020 we had 421 thousand dollars worth
of debt now we're at 323 323 000
worth of
debt or not
yes sir i'm sorry how much is that
how much of that 80
280 how much
how much non-mortgage debt oh i'm sorry
sir um three um thirty three thousand is
a vehicle seven thousand is revolving
credit card debt because of a business
my husband is a private contractor is it
ten thousand dollars is that the only
debt you have other than your house
the thirty three for a car
yes yeah so i make um at this uh my
music studio i make about forty two
hundred dollars a month when my husband
is under contract he can make in between
eighteen and twenty thousand dollars a
month he works between
um seven to ten months out of the year
he wants to retire soon but obviously we
don't have a lot of money in the bank
because of that we currently have 54k in
the bank his um
his military's retired military his
military pension will start in when he's
65.
a month sorry sir my question is where
do i contribute do i do the hsa and the
max out my my 401ks or do i do my
emergency fund first because we never
know if he's working and not working
so my emergency fund right now is at
three months
of our
expenses
it sounds like you're doing the baby
steps out of order because you're saying
you have a bunch of consumer debt but
you've got your emergency fund in place
like you're trying to do a lot of things
at once it sounds like yeah because we
never know whether or not he's going to
be having a job so
stop stop stop stop oh i don't care if
he's having a job or not he's making
plenty of money
okay
and you may need to set some money aside
that's not an emergency fund to fill in
but you're making forty two hundred
dollars a month can't y'all live on that
yeah we can
live on that that's the goal no that's
not the goal um don't stop having a goal
do it
okay our monthly bill so if you are
living on 4 200 a month then you don't
need to set back money for when he
doesn't have a job
right exactly so let's take all that
money like george said and get out of
debt a 33 000 car debt
yeah and you've been listening to me
since 2001
yes sir my husband didn't quite get on
board until after i started playing uh
your radio program every day during hold
it
so
so he he finally is on board it's that's
the next the write a check today and pay
off your car
you have to check and pay off yeah pay
off your car okay
and pay off pay off and pay off your
other debt
you're you're debt-free today but a
house and you still got 10 grand left
over if i calculated that right
yeah yeah so my question has been how do
we contribute max out the hsas and the
401ks for the tax shelter first and then
go towards retirement what is what's the
next step it'll try to get you through
baby step three
you keep jumping ahead
yeah i have a problem with being patient
yeah
and it's cost you because you have to
keep starting over
it's kind of like they all you're
you're not old enough but there was an
old
game we played in the yard where kids
called mother may i
and if you took a step forward without
being told you could you had to take
penalty steps back and that's what keeps
happening to you yeah i want you to
follow the baby steps and if you do that
you've got a lot of money in the bank
which is great because that means you
can be debt-free today and you said you
already have three months saved outside
of that
where's that yeah i have three months i
have three months saved out of that but
the money that we have in the bank isn't
a 401ks though it's not oh this is
retirement accounts we're talking so you
don't have 54 000 in a savings account
in cash
correct in cash we have a um between 18
and 21 hours you don't have a 401k in a
bank there's no such thing
well yeah i understand that we're in the
process of moving the 401k from one
institution to the next so it's in it
it's in the cash mode right now and then
they're moving it so my maybe my
description of that one okay i'm dizzy
um there's a lot going on here here's
what you need to do i'm gonna put you on
hold and we're gonna put you into
financial peace university the two of
you go to financial peace university
both of you watch the lessons together
and do exactly
what we tell you to do in that
and stop all this other crap you're
driving me nuts
i mean you you've chased your tail six
times in this one conversation
so i thought you had fifty four thousand
dollars in the bank why because you told
me that and you don't have fifty four
thousand dollars in the bank you have
fifty four thousand dollars in an ira
rollover
and you're rolling it over into mutual
funds not over into another 401k
and you need to work and get yourself
out of debt probably need to sell the 33
000 car
it sounds like you don't have the money
to pay it off and if you don't the money
paid off it needs to go bye-bye
and then we need an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses in
addition to that i need you to save some
money to cover the down months when he's
not working in a then and only then do
you start your retirement savings and
then on contract labor you use a roth
ira because he does not have a 401k on
contract labor
you have a 401k if you work for someone
else or you are self-employed and you
have a simple ira which is a 401k for
self-employed people but that's the only
thing you can do is something along
those lines and sit down and talk with a
smart vester pro they'll help you put
all that together but they will not help
you put all that together until you get
out of debt and have an emergency fund
in place
and you've got to do that before you do
anything else
do it in order and you'll not have to
start over so dadgum many times that's
what you're facing and the question was
can we retire soon no
we've got to bring this mess up you
don't have any money
you're 54 000 to your name you can't
retire you're working
sorry
you're working for a while i mean you
got a thirty three thousand dollar card
that
name close to retirement you gotta get
rid of the car you're working for a
little while the good news is he makes a
pile of money and if you'll stop
just throwing this money in 63 different
directions get yourself cleaned up get
that foundation laid in place and then
really you can pile up some a good pile
of money and retire fairly soon but
you're not going to retire this year
you're broke
you're broke you're not going to retire
this year people try to do it out of
order and they go well dave you gotta
understand my situation we got a lot
going on here yeah there is a lot going
on and that's why you need to follow
this plan to a tee because it works with
no exception so hang on kelly i'll pick
up we'll put you in the ramsey plus
membership and that'll get you guys into
financial peace university and that's
the shortest
possible
path i know to get you all to retirement
follow that exactly
so george the other thing that comes up
that um
flashed through my
i look at social media about once a
month and every time i do it's a mistake
um
it's like reading comments after an
article you ever read an article on the
internet and then read comments
successful the comments are where the
dumbest meanest humans on the planet
live is in comments you understand why
some species eat their young and when
you read comments and so social media
especially twitter is about the same
point these days
and uh but this dave ramsey's one size
fits all um
let me help you with this there are some
principles
in life
there are some principles that you
operate your life by
that one size does fit all that's why
they call them principles
tell the truth
one size fits all
you all ought to do it
you ought to be truthful you gotta have
integrity
the law of gravity
one size fits all
everyone gets to play
with equal rules
you know those who follow a proven
process in the financial world
they get a proven result
100 of the time so yeah getting out of
debt is one size fits all
just like the law of gravity everyone
should do it just like telling the truth
it works every freaking time for
everyone listening
if you can fog up a mirror it'll work
for you
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey at
ramseysolutions.com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today this is
the ramsey show thank you for joining us
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
so george 30 years ago when i started
teaching this stuff i was first teaching
people how to get out of debt
live on a budget
be generous
live on less than you make so you have a
plan you avoid debt you save money for
emergencies and later for investing
and all of those principles work but
people kept saying which one do i do
first
and so i started laying out well you
should do this first and that first you
should have an emergency fund before you
start your
401k and uh
then
i figured out it's easier to have an
emergency fund if you don't have any
payments
and so you need to get out of debt first
because of course i learned my lesson
the hard way going bankrupt and getting
out of debt and
learning how important it was to be debt
free as a process as a part of building
wealth
so all of that started to formulate
after a few years of teaching
in various settings and what became
financial peace university it used to be
called life after debt
and it started becoming what we now call
the baby steps
the interesting thing is that now the
baby steps have gone into
the total money makeover book which has
sold almost 10 million copies
and they have become the proven plan
the shortest distance between where you
are now and wealth
where you are if you live like no one
else later you can live and give
like no one else what is the shortest
distance
and we need a path to run on because the
way you eat an elephant it's
overwhelming
do i do
my 401k with the match or my kids
college or do i have an emergency fund
or do i pay on this 18 credit card debt
or
or or or or and nothing gets done you
get paralysis of the analysis you get
frozen absolutely and this step these
baby steps have worked for me they've
worked for millions and it's really
simple if you do it they work
and it all starts with baby step one
having this foundation saving one
thousand dollars for a starter emergency
fund this is just a small buffer between
you and life before we start tackling
the debt exactly and if you have a
thousand dollars already great just set
that aside that's your baby step one any
money you have that's not retirement
anything you can sell that is not
retirement you're going to liquidate it
if it's not retirement you got some
stock over here that grandpa left you
you got a gold bar under your bed i
don't know what it is but you got any
money that's above a thousand dollars
maybe you got ten thousand dollars a
savings account that's nine thousand
dollars you've got that you don't need
past baby step one we're gonna put it
all on baby step two and baby step two
is the famous one that's the debt
snowball where you list your debts
smallest to largest you pay minimum
payments on everything but the little
one and you attack the little one with a
vengeance side note baby step one should
not take you more than 30 days
maximum you need to work extra sell some
stuff have a garage sale put the kids on
craigslist whatever you got to do here
let's get it done
and you know we're gonna get busted into
this get a thousand bucks quick baby
step two you should be debt free but
your house now you may have to sell a
stupid boat
uh you may have to take an extra job but
most people that have followed the total
money makeover baby steps in financial
peace university
are debt free inside of two years yeah
and that's with doing it with some
gazelle intensity like you talk about in
financial peace university and once you
pay off all that debt now you've freed
up all those payments right you have
that income about what it'd be like to
have no payments but a house payment
wow we're breathing easy and then we can
move on to baby step three where we save
three to six months of expenses in a
fully funded emergency fund this is the
final buffer where we say we're never
going back into debt because we are the
bank now yep grandma's rainy day fund
why it's gonna rain dave you need to be
positive i'm positive it's gonna rain
you need to be ready when crap happens
there's a pandemic coming around every
corner there's something coming and if
you have twenty thousand dollars cash in
the bank three to six months of expenses
whatever it is and you have no payments
you are the third pig
in the three little pigs the one that's
in the brick house when the big bad wolf
comes you're ready for life you're ready
to go now you're ready to build wealth
but that you just now have gotten up to
ground zero you've just now gotten up to
even
when you have that emergency fund and
you're debt free now you're ready to
build wealth and baby step four you put
15
of your income
aside into good growth stock mutual
funds in retirement plans start where
there's a match beyond the match always
do roth and if you exhausted roth and
match and still are not to 15
then go on to a traditional 401k or ira
but do roths before traditional and do
match before roths
it's mathematically in your favor to do
that up to the fifteen percent don't do
twenty percent don't do eleven percent
do fifteen percent while you are doing
baby steps four you're also going to be
doing five and six simultaneously
absolutely so baby step five is where
we're saving for our children's college
fund and this is gonna look different
for everyone there's no set number here
because it really depends on your
situation did you have the baby last
week or is the baby 18
that makes a difference on how much you
need for college right what you got to
do for college it's like is this an oh
crap moment or hey we're going to be
diligent safe did we wait almost until
too late now they have to go to college
debt free they cannot participate in
this epic student loan system failure
that is called america right now it is
horrible out there do not let your kids
go in debt you do not have to go to debt
go to community college for free for two
years go go to in-state school work six
jobs get scholarships our student loan
problem is a parenting problem mom and
dad let kids sign up for crap they
couldn't afford
bad mama bad daddy
they gotta have the conversations that's
where it starts and there's a reason you
say baby step four invest for yourself
before the kids because there's a
hundred percent chance you're going to
retire there's a 50 50 chance or less
these days that your kids are going to
go to college and graduate yeah yeah
this is this less than 50 chance they're
going to graduate so
uh that that this is important so while
you're doing 15 you do whatever you need
to do for your kids college whatever you
decide to do for your kids college
beyond that if you can find any money
you do that on baby step six and that's
pay off your house
start chunking on the house now when
you're in one through three you are so
intense your friends are freaking out
your grandmother thinks you need
counseling you are gazelle intense like
a gazelle running from a cheetah when
you're in four through seven you're not
intense anymore you are now intentional
you're just doing it on purpose but
you're no longer on beans and rice your
own beans and rice rice and beans
scorched earth on one through three two
you get those three things done
now
get that house paid off the average
person following this stuff is paying
off their home in about seven or eight
years
now
that tells us that the whole program is
taking about 10 years and the average
baby steps millionaire the average
everyday millionaire that we've studied
we're finding them become a millionaire
from the time they start with intensity
followed by intentionality become a
millionaire in about 10 and a half years
yeah 11.2 years 10.6 years are the two
numbers we keep running into
so this is completely possible yeah and
once you pay off that house it's time to
build wealth and give outrageously in
baby step 7. that's where it ends yeah
you will be a millionaire shortly after
your home is paid for if you don't at
that moment and and then you continue to
build wealth and you you raise your
generosity and you continue to build
wealth and you raise your generosity and
you enjoy the money that's where it gets
fun
only three things you can do with money
and you should do all of them at baby
step seven and that's the route you're
going that's where you are that's who
you are
that is the baby steps
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today jason is in washington d.c
hi jason welcome to the ramsey show
hey george how you guys doing today
better than we deserve brother what's up
oh man i've been pondering uh purchasing
a home here been looking into it now for
about six months or so
um actually was under contract and got
out but now i'm just
pondering the whole idea over again and
wondering if it's even something that i
should get into now or if i should kind
of hold off for a while and save some
more money so just
looking for some guidance there
are you out of debt
uh so i have uh sixteen thousand dollars
um in student loan debt which is
currently not occurring interest i don't
believe it starts again until february i
believe
that doesn't matter you need to pay it
off how much money do you have saved
about 55 000. is that your only debt
i have a vehicle which i purchased a few
months ago i put 20 down on i owe about
23 000 on that
okay we teach folks jason not to buy a
house until they're debt-free and have
an emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses
plus a down payment you do not have that
much no you do not need to buy a house
right now you pay off your car pay off
your student loan build an emergency
fund and then build a down payment
how much of a down payment i mean 20
that's kind of i think what you i'd love
for you to have that because you avoid
pmi private mortgage insurance but on a
first-time home purchase i don't yell at
people for having less than that
yeah but i will yell at you for having a
car payment on a student loan when you
buy a house you're asking for trouble
right right
and i'll yell at you not only for the
entertainment value but just also to
help you
[Laughter]
yeah now i understand please i enjoy the
entertainment as well
i'm messing with you but it's all good
brother the thing is this if you buy a
house with payments you are inviting
murphy to move into your spare bedroom
your transmission will go out the first
week
yeah yeah i could probably even if i
don't you know knock it all out at once
i could probably kind of chunk away at
the student loan debt in the vehicle
over the course of the next
year no no no you misunderstood you have
the money in the bank today to pay them
off
no you're saying do it right now by the
end of the day brother
moment moments after you get off the air
you should be debt-free
gotcha okay and then build an emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
you ever heard of us talk about the baby
steps
i have i you know i tuned into you for a
while and then i stopped and i just have
to turn it on today and i i've been
listening for about the past two or
three hours two hours and
i wanted to give you a call yeah well
you heard us just describe it you heard
us describe it in the last segment right
i did i did
i actually took a couple notes oh that's
good well you know i took some notes
here too and you've got 55 in cash and
you have 39 000 in debt which means
you're debt free today with about what
sixteen thousand dollars left over which
may be an emergency fund i don't know
what that looks like for you of three to
six months of expenses only then are you
gonna start at zero and start saving for
this down payment so i know it hurts
because you've been saving up this money
but that money is not down payment money
that money is now debt money that
money's going towards your emergency
fund and then i want you to start saving
up
like dave said 20
towards that down payment and on top of
that i want you to do it within these
parameters i want you to do it on a
15-year fixed rate mortgage where the
payment is no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay
what that's going to allow you to do is
do the other baby steps and have margin
in your life to where you can actually
enjoy things
perfect that's exactly what you should
do lena is with us in tucson arizona hi
lena how are you
i'm jeremiah are you better than i
deserve what's up
i am a little bit at odds with my
husband my husband has been bit by the
solar bug
the solar boat i know that was a bug are
those loose in arizona
sometimes
uh no he is determined to get us to get
solar and i disagree as it would result
in a loan because we don't have the
finances to do it outright
and your question is what
how do i convince them it's a bad idea
why do you think it's a bad idea
it bothers me the whole idea of having a
loan just creates more financial
pressure and i feel like stressed and
i'm the one that does all the books
yeah
so
it is i i believe in solar panels i
endorse solar panel companies in several
of our 600 markets that this show airs
in
and i am not against solar at all
as a matter of fact the solar technology
is greatly advanced over what it was uh
10 or 15 years ago
and so the quality of it it's like
batteries uh in these battery operated
cars you know the whole thing's
different than it was a few years ago
the batteries wouldn't last 10 minutes
now they're last you know for 300 miles
same thing's true in solar the
efficiency has gone way up
so they're excellent products
there is not an excellent product on the
planet that i will tell you to buy with
debt
bad idea
well wait a minute it pays for itself
yeah over five years during which time
the solar panels become worth zero they
do not add value to your home there's no
market study that shows they add value
to the home equal to their cost
so the only way you make your money back
is on savings on utilities and if you've
got a five year or less break even
period that's a pretty sweet break-even
period on solar
and the only way you invest in something
with a five-year break-even period is
with cash
yeah his biggest argument is that we'd
be changing our 400 electric bill for
150 150
loan
no that's not true is the problem
because the value of the stinking things
is going down you sell the house the
loan is screwing up your house sale
you've got a mess on your hands he's
only thinking about this month he's not
looking at the overall picture it's a
very bad analysis that leads people to
finance solar panels
don't don't do it i agree with you i
wouldn't do it
anything you want to add or no i mean
that the biggest thing here is i i don't
know how much debt you guys have lena
but i want you guys to realize that debt
freedom is just a lifestyle that you're
gonna live and that means we're gonna
figure out a way to pay for this thing
in cash now i mean a sinking fund for
six months that we put this money
towards in order to pay for that in cash
that's the only way i want you to get
these solar panels
the only way that makes any sense at all
all right brittany is with us brittany's
in madison wisconsin hi brittany welcome
to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um so my husband and i are thinking of
um well we already signed up for the llc
for the cleaning business and everything
um but
my question was
should we have like
the thousand dollar savings for that we
currently have no debt except for
our mortgage and we do have three months
of expenses currently saved up anyways
okay your business finances are separate
from your personal finances yeah this
this is our personal finances but um so
far
we are just going to use money that i've
been making from my current job
to fund
this business why would you have to fund
a cleaning business you should make
money from the first day
yeah we just started with the llc so
we're just starting to try and get
clients now
yeah well the llc is not even necessary
but that's okay that's done and that's
behind you so now go get clients
you shouldn't have any expenses to set
up a cleaning business
okay
go make some money
okay
and and then let's worry about this and
no you should not quit your job to start
a cleaning business you should start a
cleaning business on the side and when
you get your cleaning business income up
until up close to what you're making
then you can afford to quit your job
until then it takes too long
okay thank you yeah you could get
yourself in trouble because you you end
up being desperate looking for clients
and taking clients you shouldn't take
taking jobs too cheap everything else
because you're running on desperation
mode yeah really important to get that
boat close to the dock oh yeah and
there's a lady in my neighborhood who
does this exact thing she's got a day
job but on the weekends she's cleaning
houses and at nights and so she comes
over once a month and this is something
that she likes she wants to do as a side
hustle and she's going maybe i'll do
this full time but you've gotta not get
enough clients maybe that's in a
neighborhood facebook group where you're
at but you can do this it's just gonna
take some time and like dave's saying i
want you to get this bow nice and close
to the dock so it's not a leap of faith
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm just sitting here drinking my call
[Music]
open phones this hour this is the dave
ramsey show the ramsey show thank you
for joining us george campbell is our
co-host in the lobby of
ramsey solutions on the debt-free stage
with a question kathy is with us from
alexandria minnesota hi kathy how are
you hi i'm good good how can we help
i have a question about the budget
i have farm rent that i get every spring
and if i put it into my budget
into my income
in the spring
i can't zero out my balance at the end
of each month so how do i put that in
there
divide it by 12 and put it in each month
but then some months i have higher
expenses in other months so
i don't not sure how to do that do you
have other income that you guys actually
live on and this is just like rental
income yes i have uh uh social security
and uh pension and you guys live on that
pretty much except for some of the
bigger things like income tax
and uh insurance some insurances okay
all right
and those are kind of once a year things
uh yes okay
so probably what i would do is just set
your budget up on everything but the
farm income
and then what i would do with the farm
income is what sharon and i do when we
have a lump sum coming in like for
instance a publisher sending us a check
on a book so royalties check okay so
similar situation we get this big check
again we know it's coming we know about
what it is
then um what we'll do is we just spend
that
one time on paper and so that means
we're going to probably put some of it
in investments we're probably gonna set
some of it aside for taxes in your case
we're gonna set some of it aside for uh
giving uh we're gonna set some of it
aside for what was the other you had
insurance insurance yeah some stuff that
you're not picking up in your monthly
budget but you know when that check
comes in once a year that it's going to
have names already on the dollars
but it doesn't necessarily
have to be monthly expenses
because if you disperse this out
112th each month if you put in a savings
account and put 112 each month into the
budget you're going to be turning around
and pulling it back out saving up for
the taxes
and pulling it back out and saving up
for the insurance sure so we're just you
know it's just dog chasing his tail then
so instead what i would do is just say
i'm going to take this one check and
give every one of those dollars a name
and set it over here with those dollars
named now what you don't want to do is
just let it sit there to miscellaneous
okay because if it doesn't have a name
on it it just disappears right and every
dollar still needs an assignment just
like in a monthly budget okay that makes
sense yes it does good way to go at it
thanks for asking thank you that's a
cool question yeah it's really a regular
income question we talk about this with
every dollar you know with sinking funds
and things where you go hey i know that
insurance is going to have to get paid
out in december so we're going to save
up for those 12 months so that's one way
to do it or you can just go hey we're
going to give every dollar a name coming
out of this lump sum yep that's the way
to go at it exactly
good question open phones here at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
bernie is with us bernie is in
massachusetts hi bernie welcome to the
ramsey show
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call sure what's up
well
two years ago we had a
paid off house and about four thousand
dollars in the bank
and no no debt
and then our house burned down
yeah it was a total loss wow um how
traumatic yeah
oh yeah we even lost our pets we didn't
even have shoes like it was it was good
it was sad
couple days before christmas you know
standing there in 17 degree weather wow
but
anyhow we were
well insured
and we have since rebuilt
um
and you know i'm i'm a cheapskate so
when we were going through this process
i was extremely
deliberate and frugal
bought some of my light fixtures at
architectural supply uh salvage places
whatever so anyhow we came out
pretty good we now again have a paid for
house
but i now have
about a hundred thousand dollars extra
because i bought used furniture i didn't
run out to the furniture store and
replace everything i own with brand new
stuff
so
i would like to know the best way to use
that money
[Music]
wow we didn't have any retirement
accounts beforehand
just before thousand dollars right how
old are you guys
my husband is 69 and i'm 62 this month
okay
sounds like you need it as a nest egg
doesn't it
yeah
the outside of the house is still not
finished i mean like the ground we've
still got like a dirt past or the front
door and we haven't paved the driveway
herox right now we're very low
no i don't know if i should hang on to
the money or you need to you need to set
a budget to finish the house
can you finish
can you finish the house for under a
hundred thousand
oh sure okay oh sure finish the house
finish the house and invest what's left
okay what like a mutual fund yeah your
house is not finished though
so you don't have a hundred thousand
dollars left
because you don't have a driveway
you have a dirt path to the front yard
you're not a hillbilly you need a dadgum
sidewalk out there
well yeah i think we could finish that
up for probably about twenty thousand
okay then you got eighty thousand
dollars is that is the house actually
finished then
yes we're living in it no i'm when you
put twenty thousand dollars in the
driveway in the sidewalk are you done
oh yeah okay what is your it would you
have income from any other sources
uh my husband collects 1600 a month in
social security
i have not filed yet for social security
even though i'm 62 this month i'm
exploring i don't know if i should file
yet or not
and one of the things we did when we
rebuilt
was i looked at the garage and the size
of the garage and thought boy that's a
lot of space above that garage so we put
in an in-law apartment when we built and
i have a son
who's renting from us
so we're getting an extra 600 a month
from the
in-law park okay well it sounds like you
need to invest the 80 000 and create
some extra income for you all to live on
yeah in good mutual funds and sit down
with a smartvestor pro click smart
buster pro at ramsey solutions select
one in your area and sit down with them
but don't do that and have a dirt path
to your front door
finish the house
and because you're going to be living
there a long time and that dark path is
gonna be
a reminder of the trauma that the the
the fire was
and the fire a fire trauma losing
everything pets and everything in the
house fire is that's a it's in one of
the it's on that list of one of the 10
things that can put you in the hospital
from stress
yeah that's very emotional and uh bernie
like dave's saying the point of the baby
steps is not to be miserable and so i
don't want you guys to sacrifice a level
where you have a dirt path going up to
your house and you have you know college
dorm room furniture because you're
sacrificing i want you guys to enjoy the
things that you have and you can do that
without going crazy i mean it sounds
like you're very frugal already but i
don't want you to go nuts on this stuff
so do what you need to do to get the
house in order to where you enjoy living
in it and you can get to the front door
and then invest the rest like dave's
talking about so that you guys can
retire with dignity
now now keep in mind if you make ten
thousand dollars on eighty thousand
that's eight thousand dollars a year
okay so we're only talking about a few
hundred dollars a month we're adding to
your budget
it's not a ton but it'll help some just
like the mother-in-law apartments
helping some with the sun with the kid
reading it and all that and so you just
keep taking those little steps but
you're going to make these you do not
have a big monthly income with all these
things added together you still don't
have a big monthly income and so you're
gonna have your your social security
check's gonna start pretty quick because
you're gonna need to add that to this
pile to be able to live on what you guys
are actually making
unless there's income coming from
somewhere that you did not outline for
some reason here yeah or that we didn't
understand do you have a rule of thumb
for when to take out that social
security depending on your situation
well in her case it sounds like she's
got to take it out because she's i think
they're starving it's necessary um but
um
you know if you don't need it the longer
you wait the bigger the check is
but um you know me i
you know i'd get it as soon as i could
get it because i want to get all i can
get out of the government before i die
fort runs out which sounds like it might
happen yeah you just never know
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day matthew 5 16
let your light shine before others that
they may see your good deeds and glorify
your father in heaven
thomas paine said reputation is what men
and women think of us character
is what god and the angels
know of us
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
david is in raleigh north carolina hi
david how are you
good thank you for taking my call dave
sure what's up
so uh
i've got a kind of a complicated
question i bought a wedding ring dave
and i'm gonna ask my girlfriend to marry
me in a few weeks and i want to
phenomenal
so i want to try to pick your brain for
a second and go over our financial
situation um so i am a 39 year old
single dad got a 12 year old little girl
i've got 67 000 saved i've got 50 000 in
my 401k 5 000 in my roth um and last
march i paid off my house which is
around 450 000 right now
um
20k
in my daughter's 529 plan
and i make about i make 75 000 a year
you have done well sir
yeah i've been at the same job for 19
and a half years and uh i've been a big
fan of yours for the last 10 so you know
just kind of really focused but uh here
is the uh here's the kicker
my girlfriend is 39 years old
she makes 211 000 a year
she makes 38 000 a year on her rental on
incomes
she owes
171 000
on
one of her rentals
44 000 on a home equity loan and then
468
000 on her primary house
now her primary is worth about 700 her
first rentals worth about 330 and she
has a 260 000 paid for rental house
already
um
and about 220k in her 401k so she's
doing quite well
herself um she's only got 8 000 in cash
savings though which we argue about that
all the time she doesn't
feel the need to to have a lot of cash
savings and i'm the opposite
um my question here is i i i enjoy the
rental houses and i i see them i see a
good future especially in the in the
raleigh durham area with these rental
houses um
and i want to attack them once we get
married and everything and we'll
probably actually tie the knot within a
few months so um
do i go after this 44
home 44 000 home equity loan
then work my way to the 171 000 loan and
then start tackling the 468 or would you
recommend me going to a bank combining
it all see if we can get a better
interest rate and attacking it that way
i'll just work through what's there
okay
now what are you gonna who where are you
gonna live
so we live in the 468 thousand dollar
house well i will be moving in with her
and then i'll be renting the 700 000
house says 468 out on it
yeah correct yes sir what's happening so
yours becomes a rental
mine's gonna become a rental yes sir
okay so you have two paid for rentals
and a primary that you owe 468 on
correct and your household income is
going to be approaching 300.
i should be around 325 but we also 171
000 on another one i got that one and
then okay no i i would knock out the uh
uh the the home equity loan that 44 very
very quickly probably out of your
savings
and then uh then then i'm going to build
up
uh from there
we'll treat that thing like credit card
debt and then i'm going to build up my
make sure i have my three to six months
of expenses set aside and then i want
you to pay off the primary
okay and then the rental last
that's surprising i i didn't expect to
hear that okay so we'll go ahead and
start attacking the 460.
here's why
okay when
crap happens like pandemics
if your personal residence is paid for
it's a different level of peace than if
your rental is paid for
okay yeah i i feel you there and so it's
like okay
it's bad for those renters over there
because i'm gonna have to sell that one
versus oh crud we're in trouble over
here at the main castle problem problem
king and queen
you know
and uh it just activates a different
part of your soul
and so
one of the things i do when i'm
answering these questions is i run best
case and worst case scenarios through my
head
and whatever the answer is it ought to
line up with both
okay and that's you know so i i like to
take an extreme worst case under what
conditions would you be having an oh
crap moment
uh and be the best off
because you know because the thing hit
the wall so to speak would there be any
harm in him selling his house that's 450
to knock out a lot of this debt there
wouldn't be and i probably would go
there except they make 300k and so they
should be debt-free on this residence in
three years 150 a year for three years
so that's the key that's the key thing
here where you go you don't need me they
had 100 income i sold this house yeah
but to get it knocked out because it's
going to take too long to pay off that
468.
but they got enough money flying around
in equities here that they can do a
shell game pretty quick and there'd be
no peace yeah underneath right i mean
you could clean up the mess pretty quick
but um
if you add it all up it's 200 uh
it's 700 000 bucks in debt
and they've got 67 000 in the bank
so
you know we could call it uh you know
650 thousand dollars in debt how quick
can you pay 650 off making 300 real
quick the whole thing's gonna be done in
five six years yeah the whole thing
and then future real estate pay cash
exactly good point good follow-up
because apparently she's got the rental
bug and he does too yeah they love real
estate so it's a good thing nothing
wrong with that but let's make sure
we're paying cash as we go good point
chris is with us in tampa hi chris
welcome to the ramsey show
good morning dave how are you good
afternoon i guess either one works for
me brother how can i help right
so my father recently passed away in
january and left me an exotic car um i'm
in the process of getting it running um
and my question was it's kind of he
bought it originally it's a 1965 356c
porsche
and he bought it originally brand new
it's a gorgeous car um
but i'm 140k basically into my house uh
i was wondering should i sell that car
and be debt free i'm debt-free other
than the house how old are you
51. okay
uh i make enough money and i think i've
got enough savings i don't have 401k i
got enough what's your household income
probably about 30.
30 000 a year
no buck 30. oh about 30. i thought you
said about 30. okay no no no that's a
little difference okay
so how quickly if you don't sell the car
does the hot does the uh 141 get paid
off
i'm two years into a 15-year fix
you're gonna pay it off in two years
no i'm two years into how quickly does
it get paid off was my question 15 years
title
no i don't know no
you make 130 000 a year how fast do you
pay off 141 000
four years
really yeah
let's start 30 000 bucks a year
okay
is that worth trading that porsche for i
don't know what i can't gauge in the on
you're the only one that can gauge it is
the nostalgic value of this
the older i get the more something that
my grandpa owned
or my dad owned means to me
i have a lot of that though that's the
thing i mean but his fortune is i'm
already getting rid of the boat i'm
selling his house
uh matter of fact probably a lot of the
assets from the house once i saw the
house can't go to pay off mine i don't
know it's just a question of you know
is that kind of money worth
future investment in future retirement
yeah
i i think that's
basically this is a this is a
collectible
that in decent condition should go up in
value not down in value i don't think
it's an investment product but i don't
think you're going to lose half the
value like you would on a new porsche um
in a you know you know in five years
which any new cars that way by the way
but um so i you know you just gotta
gauge out how much you wanna ten years
from today are you gonna be crying that
you saw this porsche
[Music]
that's that's the way you ask yourself
the question nothing's on fire here with
chris he's doing fine he's got a good
financial situation so there's no
nothing telling me yeah you got to sell
the car today yeah agreed
great good show george well done thank
you it's been fun james childs kelly
daniels in the booth i'm dave ramsey
your host we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
dave here we just launched a brand new
listener survey we want to know what you
think about the show you'll be entered
to win a 100 amazon gift card no
purchase necessary take the survey
ramsey solutions dot com
survey or text survey to 33 789
[Music]
you